hi guys scifi recap here before we start
warning spoilers ahead today i'm gonna
explain a 2013 american science fiction
and romantic drama movie starring
joaquin phoenix called her the movie
takes place in the future version of los
angeles theodore a guy who is unable to
commit to a relationship is working as a
professional online writer in a company
whose job is to compose letters mainly
love letters for people who are unable
to express their feelings towards their
partner people who need the company's
service are only required to send their
picture with their partner and theodore
will do the rest the movie implicitly
shows that a lot of people in the future
will have difficulty expressing their
feelings as the company's services are
always fully booked
paul theo's work colleague compliments
his work because of his ability to write
such amazing letters to his clients
despite his excellent work as a love
letters writer it turns out that
theodore's life is not as easy as
everyone thinks theodore is a lonely
introverted and depressed man who always
plays melancholic music and checks his
email while going home after work
the technology in the movie is already
advanced as the people completely rely
on electronic devices talking to it all
the time without doing interaction with
other people nearby
we later discover that theo is in the
middle of a divorce with his wife
catherine before sleeping he rewinds his
sweet memories with catherine while they
were still together they seemed to be a
very happy couple and theo still cannot
get over it to distract his mind he
joins a chat room's platform where he
has a pillow talk with a stranger
hoping to forget his past relationship
theo decides to purchase an artificially
intelligent operating system called os
one which is an intuitive entity that
listens understands and knows its user
the developer also claims that it is not
just an operating system but a
consciousness when the software is set
up he picks a girl's voice
the system also randomly asks about his
relationship with his mom
after the installation is complete a
woman voice who claims herself to be
samantha appears and begins to talk with
theo
she gets samantha name by reading how to
name your baby book and picks it out of
180 000 names within milliseconds
at first he feels weird talking to a
talking computer but later is fascinated
by her ability to learn evolve and grow
psychologically
samantha's other main function is also
being able to be her user's virtual
assistant she looks into theo's hard
drive contacts and help him reorganize
his email
the next day in the office samantha
shows her other magic features by
helping theo to proofread his letters
and check if there are any grammar
errors she even manages to help theo to
solve his game puzzles
they bond over their discussions about
love and life such as theo's avoidance
of signing his divorce papers because he
just still can't move on from her
a few moments later samantha suggests
theo to go on a blind date with the
women who graduated from harvard in
computer science after reading an email
sent by his friend about the women
after some hesitation he then decides to
take samantha's advice
the next day he meets up with his couple
friends charles and amy and tells them
that he is going on a date
there we discover that theater keeps
stalling time to sign his divorce paper
because of his reluctance to let go of
catherine
the bond between theo and his ai girl is
getting stronger as he shares the story
behind his broken relationship with
catherine claiming that it is his fault
for hiding and leaving her alone in the
relationship
the next day we discovered that
samantha's companion is not limited to
voice processing but she can also
analyze and visualize things through
theo's phone camera making her very
close to a real human companion
looking at the people walking on the
street with their partner samantha
wishes that she could have a body and
would be able to walk next to him
theo finally meets his date the date
goes well they share the same hobbies
and similarities both are laughing at
each other's jokes but the happy moment
doesn't last long
theo hesitates to promise that he will
see her again disappointing the woman as
she doesn't want her time to be wasted
for somebody who doesn't want to commit
to a relationship so she insults him and
goes away
at night he shares his date experience
to samantha saying that it was kind of a
weird date after that samantha and
theo's intimacy grows through a verbal
sexual encounter both of them start
fantasizing if samantha was sleeping
next to him right now and cuddling
together they develop a relationship
that reflects positively in theaters
writing at the office and well-being as
well as samantha's enthusiasm to grow
and learn on their sunday adventure theo
seems to have transformed himself into a
better version of himself happy and
energetic
samantha asks how it feels to be married
theo says that marriage is hard but
there is something that feels good about
sharing your life with somebody
he adds that catherine came from a
background where nothing was ever good
enough but because of their relationship
both of them were allowing each other to
fail and enjoy things making them grow
and change together
after work theater approaches amy and
she reveals that she is going to end her
8 years relationship with charles
because she finds charles is too
overwhelming
amy didn't want to be told where she had
to put her shoes but charles insisted
amy to place her shoes at certain places
causing them to have arguments for 10
minutes before amy decided to divorce
her husband later on theo explains to
samantha that he and amy were lovers
once in college but only in a short
period of time before he felt like it
was better to be friends
after both of them are now unofficially
single theater and amy start to spend
their free time together amy shares that
she has become close friends with a
female ai that charles left behind and
both of them begin to talk about their
relationship with an os
on the other hand theodore also admits
that all this time he has been dating an
os and he confesses he is falling in
love with samantha
after a while theo finally agrees to
sign the divorce papers that he has been
putting away and is ready to move on
he meets catherine at a restaurant where
she finally signs all the paperworks
he also mentions that he is having a
relationship with a computer named
samantha which surprises and disgusts
catherine at the same time she accuses
theodore of not being able to handle
real human emotions
catherine's statement earlier lingers in
his mind which makes theo begin to
question his abstract relationship with
samantha before leaving the office theo
meets paul and he introduces her
girlfriend tatiana to him
paul also invites him to have a double
date together so theo admits to them
that samantha is actually an operating
system but the couple seems to be okay
with that
feeling that something is wrong with
theo samantha comes up with an idea of
using physical surrogate to have sex
isabella is the one samantha locates who
is physically attractive and is also
moved by the human ai love story between
samantha and theodore isabella feels so
much about them that she wants to help
theo feels that it is not a good idea as
somebody's feelings are bound to get
hurt but samantha insists so he
reluctantly agrees to it
using a small chip samantha's voice is
in both of their ears
while theodore is hearing samantha
isabella is acting out everything the ai
says
this makes theo uncomfortable and
overwhelmed by the strangeness of the
experience
he finally decides to end this session
which makes isabella very upset and
immediately leaves his apartment
he sends a distraught isabella away
causing tension between theater and
samantha theo states that she is not
human and asks her to stop pretending
like a human which makes the ai angry
and hangs up the call
theodore confides in amy that he is
having doubts about his relationship
with the ai and amy advises him to
embrace his problems with happiness
after that conversation theo decides to
call samantha back and apologizes they
continue on with their relationship
samantha secretly compiled theo's old
letters into a book and sent it to the
publisher who liked the writing a lot
and decided to do a collaboration with
him
theater then takes his ai girlfriend on
a vacation where samantha tells him that
she and a group of other ai have
developed a hyper-intelligent os which
represents the british philosopher alan
watts
one day at work samantha is not
responding to theo and goes offline
which makes him panic and start running
out of his office
later she comes back online and tells
him that she was down as a part of an
upgrade which allows the ais to move
past matter as their processing platform
theater asks her if she is
simultaneously talking to anyone else
during her conversation with him
and she confesses that she has been
talking to more than 8 000 people as
their operating system and has also
fallen in love with 600 of them which
shows us that humans are very different
with ai
this fact makes theo very upset and
desperate but she insists that it only
makes her love for him grow stronger
eventually samantha calls theo for the
last time and reveals that she and all
the oss are going away while describing
a space beyond the physical world they
finally say their final goodbye before
she is completely gone after that event
theater finally becomes a better version
of himself and for the first time he
writes a letter in his own voice to his
ex-wife catherine expressing apology
acceptance and gratitude
at the end of the movie he visits amy
who is also upset because of the
departure of the ai they then go to the
rooftop where they sit down together and
watch the sunrise over the city
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching